the first season of Walking Dead
culminates in the destruction of the
Centers for Disease Control in Atlanta
and I can't think of a better
anti-federal fantasy than that hi I'm
Katherine manga award for reason TV and
I'm here today with paul cantor who's a
professor of English at uva and the
author of a new book the invisible hand
in popular culture thanks for talking
with us bowl it's pleasure to be here so
popular culture comes in for some pretty
negative vibes from cultural critics as
a general matter we're talking about the
Kardashians and you know reality TV and
honey boo boo you are sticking up for at
least some aspects of pulpy of popular
culture talk about why that is well
nobody ever can condemns books in
general and says all books are bad there
are a lot of bad stupid books being
written well television is the same way
the majority of stuff on television is
worthless to be honest but like any
other medium has grown up and now I'd
say probably the best writing being done
in the world today is for television
shows you say American popular culture
not only celebrates freedom it is also
itself an example of American freedom at
its best and most vibrant we're
particularly do you see that people who
defend capitalism free markets better
not attack popular culture because right
now one of the left's remaining
arguments against capitalism is that
look at how bad popular culture is my
point is that in fact we can be very
proud of the record of movies and
television coming out of the United
States again the majority of bad but the
peaks are great i would take the 25 best
movies produced in america in the 20th
century and match them against the 25
best anything except shakespeare's 25
best plays and what i mean is that free
markets do succeed in culture just the
way they do everywhere else it's a
process of trial and error and feedback
we got hundreds of people out there free
to produce what they want the public and
then choose what they like and critics
like me can choose what they think is
artistically successful you you talk
about how South Park exemplifies a lot
of your theme
and you see traces of influences of some
great political philosophers amongst the
underpants gnomes in your chapter
Cartman shrugs can you talk about that a
little bit well South Park is a perfect
example of what I have in mind it's a
really interesting provocative
thoughtful show it's a very libertarian
show it defends capitalism defends
entrepreneurship it grows out of a long
tradition of philosophical humor the
main charge against South Park is that
it's dirty the language is filthy but I
point out in the chapter that you can
find that and Rabelais you can find it
in Shakespeare you can find it in
chaucer you can find it in Mark Twain uh
where are the kind of literary
antecedents or kind of what are the
roots of the wrap-up lesson at the end
of south park I think that's sort of an
artificial device that many people know
about the show is it something about
sort of authority has to be rational or
you have to kind of derive the lesson
yourself as a viewer or is it just a
cheesy TV trope that works I think it's
more of the latter but it's a long
tradition of works of literature of
drawing some kind of moral at the end
and they're having fun with that and
really point out to people that these
shows are not the mindless entertainment
many people claim they are and some of
those endings are in fact very
thoughtful very balanced judicious
resolutions of issues I show that for
example in the episode about gay Scout
leaders that on the one hand the show
makes fun of people who don't like
homosexuals and don't want them in the
Boy Scouts on the other hand they would
be homosexual Boy Scouts leader himself
defends freedom of association I'm proud
to be gay and I program free to express
all but freedom is a two-way street if
I'm free to express myself then the
scouts have to be free to express
themselves to himself feels the Scout
should be able to exclude him not
because he would do it himself but
because that's their right as an
organization that's a very balanced
account of a very hot issue and they do
it in episode that also features a
character
named Big Gail yes that's what we're
talking about here big gay al is out and
proud excellent uh so academic cultural
criticism kind of veers between two
extremes right you have your kind of
Frankfurt School inspired popular
culture is just here to anesthetize the
masses and make them amenable to
consumption and then you have I think
this sort of maybe it's a newer critique
that we're living in this very
fragmented media landscape and that the
internet and niche publishing make it so
that no one even has kind of a basis of
common conversation anymore I suspect
you would say that both of those schools
are wrong but can you kind of talk about
why well the Frankfurt School was a
product of German émigré is coming to
Hollywood in the 1940s and for example
they didn't find Donald Duck funny hi
later but not you staged by God if I
didn't speak English I might not find
Donald Duck funny one of my thesis about
the Frankfurt School he says the product
of Emma Gray's who really didn't
understand American culture they viewed
it the way an anthropologist would view
the strange customs of a foreign land I
think it's very sad that a whole strain
of pop culture criticism has grown out
of that as for the other view they're
missing the main point that in fact
right now television is forming our
common culture for good or ill that is
what I see among my students among my
academic friends we come to a conference
about Shakespeare at dinner we sit
around discussing Breaking Bad Mad Men
and the walking dead so your day job is
teaching Shakespeare and Homer to
college students on the side you publish
about Gilligan's Island and South Park
but you have said in the past that you
would never do zombies and now your
position on that is weakening what
happened yes I finally felt too much
pressure that I ought to see if my
thesis would apply to zombies so I've
just written an essay on the walking
dead and it led me to reflect on the
widespread apocalyptic scenarios
in American popular culture now zombie
plays alien invasion and I realized that
the primary fantasy in American
television right at the moment is to get
rid of the federal government after the
blackout nothing worked governments fell
militias throws up on the world we know
is gone but keeping our humanity that's
a choice we love situations where aliens
invade and destroy the federal
government zombies show up and destroy
the federal government and people want
to see what life would be like and of
course it's tough it's dangerous but
actually and all these shows a lot of
good things results families get back
together people start homeschooling
their children they have home health
care they become self-reliant the first
season of Walking Dead culminates in the
destruction of the Centers for Disease
Control in Atlanta and I can't think of
a better anti-federal fantasy than that
on that optimistic note thank you so
much for talking with us Paul I'm
speaking today with paul cantor author
of the invisible hand in popular culture
I'm Katherine manga award for reason TV
haha